a 4 y vea 5 son los nombres de las
nuevas sub variantes del comic 19
descubiertas por los mismos científicos
que advirtieron a finales del 2021 sobre
la aparición de omicron la organización
mundial de la salud le atribuye a estas
nuevas sub variantes el aumento de los
casos en sudáfrica que hasta el momento
se presentan con los mismos síntomas
fiebre pérdida del olfato y malestar
general es demasiado pronto para saber
si estas dos variantes pueden causar
formas más graves de la enfermedad que
las otras su variantes de omicron lado
ms también advirtió de un aumento de los
contagios en todo el continente africano
y el americano aunque ha observado una
disminución de los fallecimientos y las
afectaciones graves que atribuye a la
vacunación que actualmente está en
alrededor de 11 mil 320 millones de
dosis administradas en todo el mundo
según la universidad johns hopkins
groupe bel y a nivel mundial la cantidad
de casos y muertes relacionadas con el
cob y 19 continúa disminuyendo con
muertes semanales y reportadas en su
nivel más bajo desde marzo de 2020 pero
estas tendencias aunque son bienvenidas
no cuentan toda la historia wild welcome
don't tell the full story sin embargo la
o ms agregó que está trabajando a ciegas
en algunos países por la disminución de
las pruebas diagnósticas para detectar
el coi 19 lo que dificulta la obtención
de datos que ayuden a monitorear la
evolución del virus a nivel mundial por
lo que instaron a los gobiernos para no
bajar la guardia ante la propagación de
coronavirus que aún es considerada una
emergencia sanitaria e internacional